okay today I'm going to talk to you
about noble gases we're going to have a
look at where they're found in the
periodic table we're going to have a
look at some of their properties and
we're gonna have a look at some of their
uses so first of all here are where the
noble gases are found in the periodic
table they have found in this group here
right on the right hand side core group
zero and the reason why it's not called
Group eight is a group eight would imply
that they all have eight electrons in
the outer shell was helium because it
only has two electrons it has a full
outer shell so all it's saying is all of
these have a full outer shell now all of
these noble gases having a full outer
shell gives them certain properties they
were going to have a look at in a second
so we're just gonna have a look at neon
as an example so here is neon as you can
see when I finish drawing it neon has a
full outer shell this makes it extremely
unreactive now the scientific term for
unreactive is inert so it really doesn't
undergo many reactions at all all noble
gases a mono mono atomic now this means
they just go around as one atom all by
itself they are all gasses and they will
go around a single atoms because the
fact they have full outer shells they're
extremely unreactive obviously as a
result of being so unreactive they're
really non flammable
they're extremely unreactive due to the
fact that they are so inert so
unreactive they've actually got some
good uses so number one is in filament
lamps so what we actually have in a
filament lamp is a particular filament
and it gets so hot it gets so hot that
it emits light now in order to stop this
really really hot filament right here
it's really really hot filament from
react
with the oxygen we've actually got argon
within these filament labs because it's
unreactive to stop the hot filament from
reacting with the oxygen in the air in a
very very similar way it works in flash
photography in flash photography when
you've got when you've got something
which suddenly cut has a big flash again
you want something really really inert
in order to stop it from reacting with
the oxygen in the air so also in flash
photography you could have you can
actually have argon Krypton xenon you
know to stop these reactions from
happening thirdly is in welding again a
really really similar principle due to
the fact that it's inert you could
actually use it in welding to make sure
that to make sure that it doesn't react
with the hot metal so this person here
is welding so we can make sure that that
we if we have the noble gas in the
environment here it makes sure that the
heat from the hot metal does not react
with the oxygen yeah now the final one
it could be used for airships and party
balloons now the reason why that is is
because they have a lower density than
air so here's my party balloon now it's
going to float because it has a lower
density than air okay
now the only other thing we need to know
about the noble gases is the trend as we
go down the group because the trend in
all of these following things have a
pattern so the boiling points the
melting point and the density
all increase as you go down the group so
they're lower at the top and they're
higher at the bottom now the type of
question that you might be asked about
this is let's say we got given the
density of helium as being 0.2 kilograms
per meter squared and argon has 1.8
kilograms per meters I'm sorry per meter
cubed sorry my mistake volume so the
question might be given that this is the
density for helium and this is the
density for argon can you predict what
the density for neon could be so all
you'd need to do is find the average of
those two to find halfway in between
them and that would give you 1.0
kilograms per meter cubed so it's
essentially just following the pattern -
to find the missing density
so to summarize noble gases they all
found in group 0 of the periodic table
they all have a full outer shell because
of their full outer shell it means that
they extremely unreactive like as a
result they go around by themselves due
to them being inert they could be used
for filament lamps flash photography and
welding to stop reactions happening with
oxygen in the air
due to their low density they use for
airships and party balloons as you go
down group 0 and boiling point the
melting point and the density all
increase from top to bottom and that's
basically noble gases thank you